this video is for every 17 year old 16
year old 18 year old 19 year old who's
considering going to college or quitting
college right now should i spend the
next four years going to college
hopefully i can equip the parents and
the kids to make a call with as little
societal pressure as possible when i
lived in austin my next-door neighbor
was 18 years old he was at this
important decision in his life where he
was deciding whether he was going to go
to college and i knew his parents and
it's kind of interesting because i sit
halfway between his parents and him so i
kind of have both sides he decided to
enroll at pepperdine after a semester he
didn't really like it and i think a lot
of it was because it was just kind of
expected that he'd go to college there i
had developed a rapport with him and you
know he used to work out with me at my
home gym after school and whatnot and so
i was like hey man let's go for a walk
and i think we walked for about an hour
and we just walked around the
neighborhood and i'm pretty sure that
that conversation significantly shifted
the trajectory of his life
there we go all right the reason most
people to go to college is because that
is what's expected they don't think
about the decision they just do it
because it feels like the next natural
path it's the same thing for having kids
and getting married and buying a house
but let's not get into that he went from
going to pepperdine to dropping out his
friends his family his friend's parents
started looking at him different he was
like the troubled child he was like i
don't know about him two years later he
now has 250 000 saved up as a 20 year
old makes 200 000 a year right now as a
sales guy what i want to do is break
down the split in the road of two
different lives that he could have lived
or that you could live or that somebody
that you know who's facing the decision
could go through and i'll tell you how
the conversation i had with him went
what's up man so i said listen you're at
a crossroads right now we have
crosswords every day in our lives i was
like but some crossroads are bigger than
others and when you're trying to make a
decision you have to think how
reversible is this decision and how much
long-term impact is death if i'm
choosing between chinese and mexican for
lunch it's a split in the road and it's
really not going to affect much for me
down the road choosing to go and commit
four years of my life between 50 and 200
000 of money and the lost income that i
would have made during that period of
time those are very big irreversible
decisions and they need to be treated
with the same amount of respect and a
lot of people don't because they make
that decision because their parents are
selling them to which seems like the
overused one but realistically because
they don't want to be the kid who did it
wrong who didn't do what they were
supposed to do and didn't do the next
natural step that's a terrible reason to
go to college i would like you to
approach it with a decision-making
framework that makes sense so it starts
with and this is me telling him this i
was like what problem are you solving
he's like well i want to make money so
the question is four years from now if
you have a degree and you lost the money
and you lost the earning potential you
had during those four years is that you
more able to generate income than an
alternative you because what we have to
analyze is not the cost of college but
the opportunity cost of going to college
the opportunity cost is the loss of
potential gain from other alternatives
when one alternative is chosen so when
we choose to go to college there's an
opportunity cost that exists and it is
the single greatest cost that people do
not take into consideration it's the
cost of not doing of what you could have
done in the meantime one is it's going
to cost you money because you actually
got to spend money to do it the second
way it costs you money is that you're
not going to earn what you probably
could earn full time working if that's
what you wanted to do you got two sides
there if you spent four years versus
starting a business and then four years
later the opportunity cost is the
business you could have started and what
you would have four years later so i'm
walking with him and we're this is like
a one hour really in depth like this is
probably deeper than he and i have been
because i'm still this neighbor from
across the street that like makes money
on the internet right but his parents
like trusted me enough to be like you
know i know that you have a lot of
influence over our son and like we just
want you to know that like we know you
do and so like please be careful and i
was like i'm aware he's in good hands
don't be afraid for what i'm going to
tell your son i was like listen if you
want to make money then you need income
generating skills do you think your
philosophy degree your sociology degree
your psychology degree your economics
degree even which is still a little more
useful is gonna give you actual skills
to make money he was like i don't know
and so i'm here to tell you what
actually makes money there's this lie
that has been sold that you need to
learn general education i can tell you
ancient chinese literature has never
impacted my ability to make money aztec
culture
don't know anything about it but it's
classes and they somehow fool kids into
thinking that if they take this class
they're now somehow going to be more
equipped to add value to the marketplace
if alex were redoing the education
system the majors would be in accordance
to the departments of a business you'd
have marketing and it would have the
actual ways to market which is creating
the materials of marketing and how to
distribute it you'd have sales how to
get strangers to give you money delivery
portion which would be either physical
products delivery or services delivery
which would be customer experience
customer success or it'd be technical
electrician plumber lawnmower whatever
it is so then you have the actual
technical component of the services
delivered and then you have the
supporting services which are like
finance hr legal those would be the
things that people should major in
because those are the things that you're
gonna get hired to do google stopped
requiring college degree big tech
corporations have stopped it because
they realized it too that it's not value
additive if i'm a doctor or a lawyer you
need a degree sure but for the 99 of
people who don't fall into six [ __ ]
careers that you have to have one people
were like alex you went to vanderbilt i
graduated a year early so i tried to get
out as fast as i possibly could one of
the regrets that i have is that i could
have started sooner and the reason why i
didn't drop out of college is because i
was too too [ __ ] scared to disappoint my
father if you're gonna do it eventually
you might as well do it now when i see
the guys who are starting at 18 i'm like
man i wish i had started then rather
than 23. i would have five more years
zooming back out i'm walking in the
street we're talking together and i told
him this line i said the world doesn't
need another 3-1 business degree from
pepperdine another b student who
graduates because he didn't really give
a [ __ ] right he would just do good
enough that he would get through and
this is what he brought up he's like but
what about like the social experience of
college i was like so do you think that
if you don't go to college you're not
going to be able to party with people
who are your age i was like real talk
and he was like well like kind of if the
problem to be solved is to socialize you
there are way more efficient ways to
socialize you than spending 200 000 and
not making income you can work all day
and then make my objective for this
period of time to have fun then [ __ ]
work all day and then literally go out
every single night and you'll end up
debt-free with savings and have a hell
of a crazy four stories and that's fine
if that's what you want to do i was like
is that what you want to do he's like no
and i think at some point in the
conversation he's like i kind of want to
do what you do and i was like well then
you got to learn the skills that i had
to start [ __ ] five years older than
you to start learning right and the
first thing was you had to learn how to
sell let's just go down that path if
you're watching this you're like well i
don't like sales i told you all the
other departments that you could focus
on if you're like you know what i like
being behind a camera then cool what do
you think behind a camera means in a
business behind a camera means you're
making content you're making commercials
pick one that's what video is used for
right if you're like i like writing
words what do you think writing words
are used for in business they're used to
sell [ __ ] or deliver [ __ ] that's it or
legal to protect people from selling and
delivering [ __ ] i like dealing with
people it's like well it depends are you
a little bit more aggressive you might
like sales if you're a little bit more
passive-ish and i'm not saying it's a
bad thing you might like more of like
the hr or you might like recruiting you
might like selling people rather than
selling products different ways to
thinking about it and so you can take
your skills and then bucket them into
which of these departments make more
sense and then that's what i'm going to
focus on zooming back out so i said now
we need to look at your 3-1 degree 200
000 of debt four years later versus four
years from now you're gonna have saved
money this whole period of time so he's
living with four guys because i was like
dude you're living cheap that's how this
works so he saves a lot of money which
is why he is 250 000 saved up at 20.
that's not from alex doing anything like
he worked for it he worked for it he
saved every dollar that he made and what
do you think he's gonna be able to do in
four years some people start his own
thing with a ton of capital and skills
as we're walking through these four
years what do we think happens now he's
like i really like sales now he happened
to have liked sales the blessing that he
got was he had a mentor which obviously
was me i could see his personality i was
like dude i think you'd do well here and
he did like he did well but if he was
that camera guy and he really liked more
of that stuff or if he was really techy
i would have been like dude go start
coding and so all of like you have this
bass skill and it's like where do i want
to apply it if you're like i don't know
you're never going to know because how
would you know you know by starting and
then you'll gain context to make the
decision later all you know is the
experiences you have and so all you have
to do is just always look around every
so often be like have i learned
everything that i'm going to learn from
this branch and if you've learned
everything you're going to learn then at
that point you can make the pivot right
but if you're like dude there's still a
lot for me to learn do i want to learn
that is it the direction i want to keep
going i remember when i did my first
years of consulting i looked down the
road 25 years and i was like i don't
want that life this is a hack that i
will give you for very big decisions is
that you want to keep thinking on it
keep chewing on it keep digesting it
until you can get into a single
statement which is for him four years
from now given the cost which of these
two paths will give me the most
potential for my future and he was like
well i think the other one and i was
like then what are you gonna do so he
decided to drop out and he ended up
going to sales and he was terrified in
the beginning he sucked at sales because
he had never done it before of course he
would suck and of course you will suck
too because you haven't done it but how
do you think you get good you start by
sucking and then you suck less that's
how it works until eventually you look
back after hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of repetitions and you're like
oh i'm actually pretty good at this and
it's reasonable that you'd be good
because you've done it a thousand
[ __ ] times he likes sales it's
probably gonna be the direction that he
takes directly in his life he's like
what do i need to learn now so i was
like okay how do you move up it's like
uh i could start a business i was like
yeah i was like what are you what skills
are gonna need to start a business i
gotta know how to market i was like well
you already learned how to cold calls
like that's your first acquisition
channels we got that handle which is why
i put them there it's like okay so i
have that so i can get customers all
right and i know how to sell so i got
that i was like what are you going to
deliver it's like well i really do like
teaching sales so i was like well who
the [ __ ] have you taught sales to he's
like i guess i have it i was like hmm
sounds like a skill you need to have
he's got to learn the skill of how to
transfer a skill from himself to
somebody else what are the other skills
he's going to have to learn well he's
going to have to learn how to do
finances he's going to have to get
contract set up so you can have services
agreements things like that but again
these are all googleable things that you
can do you can figure those things out
in a couple days it's not a big deal for
the parents who are watching and the
kids who are watching this at home are
trying to make the decision is do i
think that four years from now with 50
to 200 000 in absolute cost and probably
higher than that an opportunity cost of
the cost of the path not taken which of
these two paths will lead me closer to
where i want to go and if the goal is to
to make income then you have to look at
that 200 000 and all the things you
could buy with that 200 000 in four
years of time and think is there another
way that i could reverse engineer four
years to get me to where i want to go or
if you just really like the technical
expertise that you have you go super
deep on the technical expertise and then
you bolt on one additional skill this is
the one skill i will give you that you
need to bolt on to instantly give
yourself the lift in whatever career you
have you gotta learn how to deal with
people you gotta learn how to manage you
gotta learn how to lead you're like that
sounds like the soft tough and it is but
it's also how you're gonna get promoted
it's how you get respect it's how you
gain influence and you also realize that
the technical thing that you're really
good at is probably not the thing you're
gonna be doing in the business you just
gotta know it well enough to teach it to
somebody else his parents came to me
after like i talked to him and they're
like alex can you please just tell me
again on why he should be you're like
telling him to to quit college i was
like i'm not telling him to quit college
i'm telling him to make the best
decision for where he wants to be in
four years i'm not telling him not to
get educated i'm telling him to get
super educated in the thing that he
wants to do the best people in the world
anything learn for themselves they are
self-taught if you can adopt that
mentality then the world is your oyster
because you realize that you can learn
whatever you want whenever you want you
don't need a certification or permission
to do that which of these paths four
years from now given the opportunity
cost is going to get me furthest towards
my goal
here we go all right what's up man
what's up
what's up so i was responding to the
comments that you had that they didn't
think that you were real
so
this is uh this is to my my youtube
audience to know that jacob is indeed a
real person can you confirm that you
lived as my neighbor next to my house
and that we did work out every day after
school
yep and then how are you now
i am 20. i still can't drink yet tough
life um
so you're in sales now right what are
you making right now i'll probably hit
2.50
nice to be king and then how much money
you have saved up
210. okay so over i it was i thought
there's two i thought it was 250. i got
the 250 mixed up so it's 210. what would
you say has been the like the biggest
mental mind shift change etc from uh
from our talks in our chats
that's a good question
[Laughter]
well you decided not to go to college
right is that the walk that did it
i did i did go really aggressive on that
walk to be fair so you had now at that
point been in school for a semester what
was the reason you decided to take that
jump
i think that the the line that really
hit when you said
and i'm paraphrasing it
it's mostly acceptable to fail at
entrepreneurship because you're still in
school and you're using it as a crutch i
think that that was like oh that's it
yeah so you were because you were
dabbling on the side and you weren't
succeeding at the entrepreneur thing
which is what you really wanted to do
and you were using college as a social
safety net to give yourself an excuse
for why you weren't winning
exactly and so then you uh decided to go
all in on it
then we went all in we did it
all right say hi to me
you're in the closet
say hi to mozy nation
so that is to confirm that jacob is
indeed a real person uh with a real
pulse and a real story and if it worked
for him it could work for you
thanks i appreciate you go back to your
sales calls
[Laughter]
jacob was lucky as hell that he just
happened to have been my neighbor um
that's right jake i could just tell that
he was incredibly hungry i knew that he
had this really deep desire to prove
himself when i see something like that
i'm like cool like and the way i tested
that i was like shop after school every
day we'll work out
and i wanted to see if he would show up
and like clockwork no matter what every
day he would text me it wasn't like me
having to text him or remind him i knew
that he had that desire and he would
take as much as i was willing to give if
this video caused you to question a
couple things or maybe even brought up
more questions than it did answers
because it opened up your mind to some
things what i'd recommend doing is
watching this video my video about how
to analyze opportunities and so if
you're looking at okay maybe i don't do
college but what path do i go on that
will give you the framework to make the
decision on how you analyze opportunity
in your life and a business that you
might potentially start etc hope you
enjoy they're like when are you going to
start like hormoza university and like
train these guys on the scales and maybe
someday